e a educação faz parte de sermos humanos
não é à toa que temos ensinamentos são
passados desde a formalizada até na
forma escrita também mas há algo que se
passou desde o teatro de Gil Vicente da
Roma antiga do Iluminismo e da Revolução
Industrial do cinema e do stendapy que
também se evoluiu que é a parte do Inter
atendimento esse até o entretenimento
evoluiu nós vamos analisar também que a
parte da educação ela vai também ter um
avanço e um desenvolvimento que vai
fazer com que seja diferente São Carlos
uma cidade que respira educação nós
temos três universidades como a USP ao
Oscar e a Unicep Sem contar os polos que
estão à distância de universidades que
tem o ensino híbrido ou até mesmo ensino
online nós temos também o Sesi o Senac
temos escolas de ensino médio de Ensino
Fundamental tanto da rede estadual conta
da rede
bom e até mesmo da rede privada e
municipal esses um experimento de
milgram que diz que nós estamos a seis
espaços as três graus de conseguir
conectar-se a qualquer tipo de pessoa e
a qualquer pessoa no mundo se ele fosse
fazer esse experimento aqui em São
Carlos para poder relacionar com uma
pessoa que estivesse na educação Talvez
esse 6° diminuíram parar 1° apenas nós
temos professores pesquisadores e
funcionários todos eles relacionados com
a partir do Cação aqui em São Carlos e
uma coisa que já estava engatinhando que
acabou se intensificando de 2020 para
agora é o AD mas é presunçoso falar que
cuidar dele estava caminhando
vagarosamente desde a década de 60 e 70
nós já temos a possibilidade de poder
aprender por meio de correspondências e
até mesmo cartazes poderiam nos trazer
informações e ensinamentos e instruções
educacionais o que a gente tem
intensificado agora é a parte da
internet
o criado desde o ensino básico até o
ensino superior se antes não precisar
somos ir para uma escola para poder ter
uma instrução agora podemos fazer isso
em casa Porém o que há de muito choque é
que a parte do que acreditamos o que tem
que ser ensino Tradicional em uma
instituição ele precisa ser um mesmo
para o que ela ensinou online se a gente
tem essa possibilidade de que em redes
sociais na internet nós podemos tanto
participar com uma alunos e pessoas que
estão aprendendo a parte da educação
nessa nova era de educação a gente
precisa entender que na verdade temos
até que fazer alguns processos
diferentes O que temos de ensino
tradicional o grande e é o que temos
agora de acreditar que as mídias sociais
de que a internet e de que os sites
precisam ter o mesmo enquadramento e o
mesmo passo a passo do que tem do ensino
tradicional dificulta nós passarmos para
esse novo estilo de educação é difícil
não dá
de novo eu não tenho tempo a matéria
dele é mais fácil de fazer é muito comum
ouvir isso de profissionais da educação
quando a gente vai falar de transmitir a
nossa aula do ensino tradicional para um
ensino online sem contar também alguns
impedimentos que acreditamos que na
verdade vão impedir que conseguimos
fazer um ensino online como a gente
precisar de materiais profissionais como
câmera sofisticadas computadores
sofisticados edição de alta qualidade
para poder produzir um conteúdo de
ensino online eu não solto produtivo eu
não consigo estudar ele tem mais
facilidade em casa eu não tenho sossego
sem de ovo de uma das partes dos
professores de como produzir ouvimos
também dos alunos que não conseguem
estudar sem contar de número as
plataformas que precisamos acessar para
poder conseguir estudar e também da
desmotivação de que os alunos precisam
ser produtivos a todo momento em uma
quantidade muito maior quando falamos do
ensino online ou até mesmo que chamamos
hoje de ensino híbrido entretanto
Ninguém Vive apenas de
o tanto esse sentimento que os
professores possuem quantos alunos de
que a todo momento eles precisam ser
produtivos isso é praticamente
impossível de se conceber a gente não
consegue mesclar esse sentimento que a
gente tem de produtividade como também
conseguir descansar assim como do
entretenimento com a parte da educação é
meio difícil a gente conseguir fazer com
cliente tenha separadamente uma das
coisas independente da outra é
praticamente como sente os falar de
física sem falar de matemática como se
fosse falar de literatura sem falar de
história como se a gente quisesse fala
de Minas Gerais sem falar do pão de
queijo ou do Rio de Janeiro sem falar do
Cristo Redentor e até mesmo fala de São
Carlos sem falar da pizza de alface e
para que fique mais claro esse
relacionamento que a gente consegue
mesclar o entretenimento com educação aí
que eu preciso entender o que talvez é a
antiga educação ou que podemos chamar de
educação tradicional como ela funciona
como a se configura e o que que essa
nova educação possa fazer
eu perdi diferente em que também se
recupere do clássico para a gente poder
conseguir avançar e fazer com que a
gente tem um ensino adaptado e melhorado
tanto dos professores quanto para os
alunos se compararmos o ensino
tradicional com que temos de 100 online
a diferença mais gritante de todas é um
local sente por compara ao que a gente
tem condição tradicional com quem eu
tenho do ensino online aí que pode
perceber que se uma pessoa ela vai até
escola e ela fique 5 horas naquela
escola e também ela vai ter as próprias
de professores e talvez ela não tem esse
do pedido de nenhuma atividade nova o o
Tempo Passa alguma material nova
simplesmente ela vai dizer hoje o dia
foi longo só que quando a gente compara
com que temos de ensino online a todo
momento temos um envio de links temos
que fazer em suas atividades a gente
passa de uma sala de zoom para outra ou
até mesmo de Google Maps para outra e
ficamos com o sentimento de que a gente
faça o mesmo tempo e a gente se sinta um
produto
e insatisfeito com o nosso dia existe
uma pequena movimentação que existia
antigamente com ensino tradicional que a
gente acabou perdendo Por que a todo
momento temos uma residência de começo
meio e fim que ficou insuportável tanto
para o aluno quanto para o professor é
só você lembrar quando a gente tinha as
pequenas movimentações de uma sala para
outra quando os professores faziam
pequenas perguntas e o Corinthians Qual
foi o último episódio do BBB que que
aconteceu e como é que vocês estão essas
pequenas coisas que entramos em contato
com os nossos alunos que os tornam mais
humanos e que nos tornam mais ou menos
como professores acabou se perdendo
porque a todo momento a gente precisa
ser produtivo aí tem que ser incansável
e temos que seguir uma rotina de que por
sermos mais rápido na internet a gente
acha que a gente tem que ser mais rápido
a todo momento EA cada vez mais em vez
de pensarmos que a gente precisa adaptar
Aí tem que fazer idêntico no ensino
online não é uma até
a temperatura que se torna por si só
interessante que o aluno se pegarmos
esse conteúdo que o aluno precisa
aprender para poder fazer uma produção
de Podcast ela pode se tornar mil vezes
mais interessante do que ela seja apenas
passada se a gente tem uma lista de
exercícios de gramática com suas regras
que pode ser transmitida para um poço de
Instagram e se não pode se tornar muito
mais valioso um desafio de matemática
que ele é passado que os alunos precisam
produzir para que o professor responda
pode tornar o ensino diferente para
quando a gente se aplica matemática e um
quiz de biologia que ele pode ser
substituído por dezenas e dezenas de
slides que não deveriam ser apresentados
quando a gente vai relacionar esses dois
fatores que temos de ensino tradicional
início online Os dois podem se aplicar o
mesmo tempo só que quando a gente fala
de mídias sociais quando falamos de
aplicações até mesmo de Facebook e
Instagram Tik Tok YouTube podemos
perceber que finalmente a gente parte
para um novo rumo da educação que o
ensino
tá dando que a parte do infotenimento é
informação com entretenimento o que a
gente tem como entretenimento é
simplesmente telhado esse papel punitivo
da educação de um lousa giz papel e
caneta da parte de quem a gente pode
fazer com que ele tem uma atividade que
ele possa se divertir que ele possa ser
lidado com um Desafio ou até mesmo
saindo padrão para que ele possa ter um
novo conteúdo Lembrando que
entretenimento não precisa
necessariamente cair na gargalhada o
professor ele não precisa fazer uma live
de free Fire World League of Legends e
não precisa fazer um remix de memes
quando a gente pega para ir nós mesmos
avaliar mas o que fazemos as nossas
mídias sociais nós estamos a todo
momento aprendendo enquanto nos
divertimos o grande ponto é que a
educação se tornou tão punitiva que a
pergunta vale nota só tem mostrado como
que cada vez mais a educação está
associada com um sistema punitivo senão
vale nota então eu não vou
e a partir do momento que a gente
consegue perceber que podemos fazer com
que a educação ela possa passar por um
processo de infotenimento ela sai de um
esquema de que a todo momento você
precisa receber nota para uma atividade
para que você possa se divertir com uma
atividade sente tem esse sistema de nota
e que obriga o aluno que a todo momento
ele presta atenção e em nenhum momento
ele possa avaliar se ele vai começar se
ele está no meio ou se ele vai terminar
a educação faz com quem é que tem um
sistema de Aula dada aula estudada se a
gente tem a possibilidade de que podemos
convidar os alunos enquanto no meio do
semestre eles estão desmotivados Mas
agora eles ganharam motivação nós temos
uma educação que passa para 365 dias se
um aluno decidi começar a estudar um
curso de inglês ele vai poder só fazer
em janeiro ou pode fazer em Julho ele
não pode fazer em nenhum outro tipo de
tempo só que com a educação online com
infotenimento ele pode decidir fazer em
abril fazer em Julho faz em setembro ou
quando ele
é inspirado por que ele tá percebendo
que ele está aprendendo e não sendo
punido e o grande problema para
professores e alunos Zé Quais são os
exemplos Será que em um vídeo que é
gravado no YouTube para poder você
conseguir avaliar esse aluno é mais
informativo que uma lista de exercícios
se vamos pensar que um podcast ele vai
conseguir substituir uma lista de
exercícios de vestibulares Isso vai ser
mais significativo o que a gente pode
ver é que a gente está aprendendo a todo
momento quando utilizamos as nossas
redes sociais só que a gente não
consegue olhar com um passo para trás
Como infotenimento já acontece ele já
está acontecendo dá uma coisa que ela tá
começando aparecer o cliente precisa ver
é que em cada uma das plataformas e
menos o que consumimos hoje no nosso
celular no nosso computadores nossos
tablets já está inserido com
infotenimento e o que que a gente
precisa ter é a percepção para poder
conseguir adaptar isso para o ensino
online o Instagram
é tão mais utilizada no mundo existem
dois milhões de pessoas que já fizeram
um download desse aplicativo e uma das
grandes Vertentes uma das grandes
possibilidades que existe é que o
conteúdo dele praticamente morrem 24
horas e significa que existe uma enorme
possibilidade de a todo momento você
trazer um novo conceito porque novas
pessoas estão entrando nessa rede social
a todo momento a gente pode gravar
vídeos curtos podemos levar vídeos
longos fotos podemos comprar uma
sequência de fotos de assuntos que
pessoas estão entrando a todo momento e
tenha oportunidade nova de aprender um
conceito que não precisaria estar
inserido nesse de Aula dada é aula
estudada e o Tic Toc não é só um
aplicativo de dança se a gente conseguir
nessa linha de raciocínio Como que o
Instagram tici de nasceu o seu origem no
como parte de uma rede social a com você
apenas colocava fotos hoje faz com que
seja possível que temos contas de
estudos aí a gente pode fazer assim como
nos
a gravar pequenos vídeos curtos
explicando e convencendo pequenos
conceitos como pílulas medicina como
pelos educacionais Com pequenas dicas
para que os alunos possam acumular esse
conhecimento e se for tanto assim de que
a gente tem esse a percepção de que o
Tik Tok apenas um aplicativo de dança
Podemos fazer também que em uma das
partes que podemos avaliar o aluno seja
de uma dança explicando um conceito que
foi passado em sala de aula o Facebook
ele cria uma dinâmica de grupo sa Qual o
Instagram e o Tic Toc não tem muito bem
só que se não tira o fato de que ele
também possa ser utilizado assim como
Instagram e no Tik Tok para poder ser
avaliado e também ser produzido como
conteúdo tanto dos professores dos
alunos existem grupos de estudos As
quais você pode receber tanto
explicações de alunos quanto de
professores também sobre as matérias
inclusive é um ótimo local para que você
tenha memes e os memes eles são nada
mais nada menos do que uma realidade que
temos passado com o verossímil algo que
aparece o nosso
Oi e para que possamos entender a graça
do mesmo é necessário também que você
conseguir entender o contexto entendeu
um conteúdo que se passa para ter aquela
expectativa e humor esse a partir disso
nós temos a criação de um meme temos
também uma aprofundamento E também temos
a prova de que a pessoa está aprendendo
e consegue entender tanto na produção
quanto no consumo desse conteúdo já um
Twitter ganha pela simplicidade sem a
gente tem uma rede social com você vem
ficar com 280 caracteres é possível que
a gente passa tanto a uma frase curta
explicando um conceito ou também pediu
para que os alunos façam também esse
tipo de explicação Então os professores
e alunos podem entrar nesse nessa mídia
social fazendo com que ou seja possível
fazer uma explicação ou até uma
discussão com uma cadeia continua de
tweets isso faz com que seja possível
tanto a discussão de assuntos atuais em
termos de política até mesmo de assuntos
que nunca imaginávamos ter ou que
poderiam existir ou que existem porque
eu nunca estaria percebendo se não fosse
a Maravilha que a internet trazendo
esses novos assuntos apesar de ser um
estilo e não propriamente dito uma mídia
social o podcast também uma outra
possibilidade que você pode encontrar
tanto no Spotify quanto no YouTube o que
se faz é basicamente você utilizar o
áudio para que você tem um novo conteúdo
e se pode ser feito para que você tenha
uma matéria que ela poderia ser passada
apenas com o professor explicando de uma
forma que você possa fazer com que o
aluno Produza um conteúdo que faria com
que aquela aula tem um rumo diferente e
até mesmo você pode fazer com que os
alunos criem patrocinadores e crie uma
logomarca para que esse Pode fechar e se
torne cada vez mais verossímel e ele tem
um aspecto que se torne menos mas antes
e menos conteudista e toda essa forma do
infotenimento ela começa a ser mais
humana ela para deter um aspecto tão
conteudista e tão bastante porque ela
ganha um rosto humano ela ganhou um
aspecto humano ela ganha uma realidade
que
e vamos antes excelente Alex só poderia
ter a possibilidade de poder começar a
estudar ou em Janeiro ou em junho ou que
apenas nosso conceito era Aula dada aula
estudada e nunca Poderíamos voltar atrás
para poder relembrar de um conteúdo ou
tem uma nova visão ou uma nova dica ou
até mesmo atividade que fosse diferente
agora temos essa possibilidade Então
esse infotenimento traz uma
possibilidade de que a nossa educação
não fique apenas de conteúdo conteúdo
conteúdo repetitivo mas sempre um
convite para que possamos ver com outros
olhos um conteúdo que a gente sempre viu
na nossa frente se a todo momento nós
vamos nas mesmas redes sociais e vemos
conteúdos parecidos mas que cada um tem
um aspecto novo a mesma coisa pode
acontecer com a educação nós temos
sempre a mesma matéria só que a todo
momento ela pode ganhar um novo convite
uma nova forma com uma pode aparecer ela
pode aparecer como um vídeo com uma foto
com uma sequência de tweets
Ah é mesmo como um Carrossel ou uma
dança viral o infotenimento é um convite
para que tanto os alunos e os
professores possam perceber que a
educação não precisa ser maçante e
repetitiva isso não significa que o
ensino tradicional ele não tem a sua
valia mas o que nós podemos perceber é
que existem outras possibilidades e
outras opções que podemos fazer com que
a educação ela deixe de ser repetitiva e
ela possa ser adaptada para que podemos
perceber tanto com o nosso como eu
professor que precisa produzir educação
que podemos conversar com os alunos
sobre novas possibilidades de tanto ser
avaliado quanto também assumir e
assimilar um conteúdo isso não significa
que nós estamos cá nós estamos
caminhando para uma nova era de educação
nós já estamos Essa era de Educação de
mídias sociais e de infotenimento o que
eu faço aqui é apenas um convite para
que você passa também parte do
infotenimento na
é isso não significa que eu estou aqui
com uma parte da estação eu quero que
você me veja com um exemplo e que venha
fazer exemplos comigo tanto você aluno
quanto você é professor Muito obrigado